[Music]
the service dogs in training are gearing
up for a big day for any student some of
the best days of school are days like
today field trip day even though field
trips mean a day of new sights sounds
and smells these puppies are going to
have to stay focused if they have any
hope of passing puppy prep
[Music]
the dogs are loaded into the van and
driven to today's field trip location
rooster Creek Park for all the puppies
it's an exciting day but for kaya
especially the pressure is on today is
her first field trip at doggie doo good
the first time the trainers will get to
see how she does in public if she or any
of the other dogs become too distracted
while off-campus they could fail out of
service dog school rooster Creek Park is
a park in downtown Arroyo grounded with
a bunch of freaking roosters running
around the ample opportunity for
distraction provides a great test for
the dogs focus the tests they must pass
since trainers Paul and Karen can only
work with one dog at a time they find a
shady spot to put the dogs into a down
stay the dogs can only get up after they
hear their name and the word really
exists this is one of the most basic but
crucial commands for the pups to master
and doing so on a field trip is good
practice when they train a doggie do
good
the puppies we're only bandanas during
field trips however they wear their
working vests the do not pet best help
the dogs maintain focus owners who
suffer from PTSD seizures diabetes and
other issues could need help at a
moment's notice if someone is
distracting their dog by petting them
the owner could fall into serious
distress heck even the undeniable mr.
pip has a tiny vest don't worry
the dogs get plenty of pets but when
they're wearing their vests they need to
focus
[Music]
so far Kyah seems to be doing well on
her first day out down stays her
specialty
but her trainers do not know she's been
exposed to so many chickens apart from
all the chickens and again there are so
many chickens rooster Creek also
features an old-fashioned swinging
bridge the pups need to be comfortable
walking across all kinds of surfaces so
the bridge is a great test of their
focus first one up is the veteran Deacon
at almost two years old deacon is mere
weeks away from graduation by now you've
no doubt noticed deacons harness you're
polite to ignore it but it's fine you
can stare deacon is a stability dog one
of his special commands is steady steady
when Deacon hears this he tenses up so
his humans can use him for balance even
on stairs Deacon needs to be able to
provide additional stability deacon is
also a retrieval dog he loves holding
things in his mouth and can carry light
bags for his owner if someone dropped
something Deacon loses his mind with
excitement at the chance to pick it up
keys a wallet even a spoon I mean I
think even a spoon well would you look
at that he actually used his paw to get
the spoon this is one puppy who really
wants to pass
[Music]
it's kaya and her brother Luke Stern
with the trainer's as owner sandy
watches the dogs and down stay so far
the golden retrievers seem only slightly
curious about the Roosters this is a
good sign they're not scared but not
aggressive towards the birds either
still they need to maintain laser focus
to work on their commands while Deacon
specialties were steady and get it Luke
is learning alert the golden is trained
to get his owner's attention when he
hears an alarm go off this could be a
reminder to take medicine or a
malfunctioning insulin pump also if an
owner is prone to anxiety or PTSD
attacks Luke is being trained to act as
a smokescreen of sorts when Karen taps
her thigh Luke will jump up and start
nipping becoming a general distraction
this allows the owner to excuse
themselves to quote go and deal with
their dog extricate themselves from the
problematic situation kaya hasn't been
working with the trainer's long enough
to have any special workouts everyone's
just pleased that she seems to be
handling her first field trip
beautifully with the day at rooster
Creek Park done it's time for the pups
to go home some of the animals stay at
doggy do-good while others go home with
employees - puppies that go to trainer
homes at night are Benelli and her best
friend Cleo they began the program at
the same time and though they look like
siblings they aren't related
Cleo goes home with volunteer Christina
even though she wasn't on the field trip
Cleo still had a big day of training
back at doggie doo good now it's time
for her to just be a puppy
while Christina won't make Cleo go
through drills she still needs to make
sure Cleo is obeying the basics of being
a civilized poem if Cleo chews on
something or has a potty accident
Christina has to stop what she's doing
and handle it Cleo can get shy
especially around loud noises but this
isn't the time to work on that Cleo can
relax and worry about her training
tomorrow speaking of tomorrow that's
what time it is now and what luck it's
time for another field trip because all
the dogs did so well with all those dang
roosters running around rooster Creek
it's time to see how they'll do with
other animals at Avila Valley Barnes the
first priority for every puppy on any
field trip is to taste the local flavor
of grass as well-trained as these pups
are there are some things they just need
to grow out of once again deikun is the
first to work the trainer applies
occasional pressure on deacons harness
to make sure he's always ready to
stabilize someone the emu is only a
temporary distraction and Deacon is
still able to retrieve items with it
nearby Deacon recognizes even though
it's a fun day at the farm he has a job
to do next to go on a lap around the
farm is Benelli
things that didn't phase two-year-old
Deacon could be a major distraction for
the six-month-old lab whenever Benelli
meets something new that could startle
her the trainer feeds her a treat in pet
sir this boosts the young pups
confidence and gets her to associate
nervousness with treats these field
trips are all about positive
reinforcement in unfamiliar situations
such as the EMU which doesn't faze
Benelli this cow is unfazed and so is
Fanelli when a stranger approaches
however her body language changes she
subtly presses against trainer Paul a
clear indication that her confidence
needs to be sharpened back by the dogs
and down-stay the undeniable mr. pip is
restless
he is so attached to doggy doo good
owner Sandi that while she's around he
can barely focus because the plan is for
his future owner to carry mr. pip most
everywhere this is less of a problem
than it would be with the larger dogs at
his size he's much more vulnerable to
the large animals that freaking goat
just tried to tear mr. Pibbs head off
believe it or not courage has been an
issue for the small yorkshire terrier
it's crucial he unlearned this behavior
so he isn't distracted when he's needed
to leap into action
for instance when he needs to work on
his pressure therapy commands mr. pip is
able to give hugs and kisses on command
when he hears the command happy mr. pip
job is to become a calming happy
presence this can soothe people with
emotional issues when a dose of puppy
love is just what's needed back with the
dogs and downs day Deacon has discovered
a way to cure his boredom without
getting into trouble he reaches his paw
out to tempt a classmate
that way he has a friend and hasn't
broken his down stay very tricky deacon
stop getting the puppy into trouble
you're supposed to be a role model now
it sky has turned to toward the farm
like Benelli and mr. pip she too needs
to work on her courage but it's a tough
balance between becoming familiar with
new things and being distracted the pups
need to be comfortable around everything
but these goats are testing them the
trainer's are sure to praise kaya up
when the stupid goats scare her this
helps kaya know she's alright meanwhile
mr. pip has found a friend these pups
spend most of their schooling around the
adult trainers but for dogs that are
going to families with children it's
important they get exposed to kids
children have a different energy and way
of interacting with animals for people
loving kaya
it's no problem she is a blast as the
children take her through the cluster
phobic hey mates mr. pip also is already
a pro around kids a good sign for one
he'll eventually interact with children
every day for some of the young pups
today's a day of exploring not just the
farm but also hidden talents trainer
Karin is testing Bonelli's knack for the
command get it someday she might be as
good as deacon well as good as deacons
sometimes is
but for now the trainer's are curious to
see if it's something the pup would even
like to do and it appears she would
Benelli has much more enthusiasm for the
drill than Karen had even expected
Benelli is a strong desire to please
which is a key quality in service dogs
now it's a matter of building her
confidence over the following months
with the day drawing to a close there's
still time for a quick class photo today
one well but tomorrow will be another
day of unexpected challenges challenges
that might be too much for one of the
students sleeve type pups
[Music]
you